okay let's go to the phones a very crazy
week and a lot of people wanting to
wanting to chat the number is six one
seven eight three zero
4750 let's pick up first on our caller
from the 8:06 area code caller from 806
what's your name where you calling from
today Ally is it me yes it is all
pac-man it Pedro from Colombia hola soy
Pedro Oh
Davian you know I haven't talked to you
in a while you know I had a question for
you see cuando me oh yes I'm Allison
tiempo no hace cuanto tiempo oh come on
man I'd rather speak in you not in
Spanish you know cuz you know I'm trying
to learn I mean not in Spanish about any
English yeah last time you can try a
little thought that you were faking you
didn't really speak Spanish but I guess
you do
oh yeah - well you know my wife and I
are trying to learn English you know so
you know I'm just trying to speak here
right now and I get it a lot from
watching you mr. Baughman una pregunta
más en espanol the kiss sudha in
Colombia sauce or other capital for
anyway L capital o commercial capital
Qualis okay well anyway so here's why
I'm doubting Pedro because any Spanish
speaker would know it's la capitale not
el capital and they would know what the
capital of their home country is you
know what I mean at the name of the city
you know L capital o I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
that explains a lot that explains a lot
oh yeah it confuses a lot of people to
me I was conversion
okay but anyway so I'm seeing the
election going on you know yes we've
already well I couldn't vote you know
what I guess so
I'm kind of worried you know cuz I don't
know how like the conventions gonna go
on you know cuz I don't know how you can
do it with like everybody said you know
everybody shows up and then and then Joe
Biden he catches a corona virus you know
so I'm kind of worried you think they're
gonna like do it over the Internet you
know phone call no I have no idea Pedro
but you know our team is looking for El
Capitan in Colombia and we're not
finding it with which province is that
in oh you know it's been a while mr.
Bachman you know I'm like I might have
to get back to you on that no you don't
know what anyone's you're from oh yeah
you do no no no I I do know like not
right now you know Pedro this is very
interesting I'm gonna let you go okay
we're really having a tough time
figuring out is Pedro really a Colombian
guy or is he trolling last time people
were convinced he was trolling he said
he's from El capital we can't find El
capital in in our very cursory search I
don't know
I paid ro is a very good subtle troll or
something something else is going on I
don't know I want to tell you about one
of our sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk and now breakfast has gotten
much more boring magic spoon is a new
cereal company that has discovered how
to recreate your favorite childhood
cereals with zero sugar 12 grams of
protein and just three grams of net
carbs per serving they offer four
flavors based on the classics cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry plus the
variety pack which lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon dot-com slash Pakman promo code
Pakman for shipping